MALE SPEAKER: "The Skeptics
Guide to the Mind--
What Neuroscience Can and
Cannot Tell Us about
Ourselves." The first two
chapters are about out of body
experiences, phantom limbs,
problems assigning agency to
our own actions.
And Doctor Burton describes many
of the same reports that
are trotted out in the scores
of popular books on
computation--
on Neuroscience and
the brain--
more often than not, with
some of the unsupported
interpretations that are
floating around about what
this data means.
He points out that even
reputable Neuroscientists are
as quick to fuel the public
appetite for disturbing
anecdotes and attention
getting soundbites.
What Robert's book helps the
reader to do is to revisit
some of the many patient cases,
animal studies, MRI
recordings, from a different
perspective, offering
alternative explanations and
dissecting the way these
results are explained in
the popular press.
And why so many of those
explanations are misleading,
premature, and needlessly
theatrical, essentially
pandering to our high opinion
of our own vaunted brains.
But having studying Neuroscience
for now about 20
years about 10 years--
excuse me--
it seems--
and taught a course at Stanford,
I thought I was
pretty savvy about neuroscience
and the ability
to parse out the true
facts and reading
some of these papers.
But in several instances, Robert
helped me to recognize
how I had allowed language and
hyperbole surrounding the
public versions of these
scientific studies to
insinuate itself into
my scientific view.
Robert's new book seeks to
exorcise some of these
comfortable and often
compelling, but ultimately
misleading, views of
Neuroscience It's
a thoughtful book.
It's a really intriguing
and fun book to read.
And I'm looking forward to
what he has to say today.
ROBERT BURTON: Thanks, Tom.
[APPLAUSE]
Is that too loud
or just right?
It's OK?
Because I tend to talk
really quickly.
I'm from the era where
you paid for the
phone by the minute.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT BURTON: And if you guys
have to leave now, this slide
sort of is the main takeaway,
namely, though we don't like
to admit it, the tools of
Neuroscience are not fMRI
scans and inter-cellular
recordings.
The primary tool for studying
the mind, as opposed to the
brain, is the mind itself.
We dream up to questions.
We dream up the experiments.
We write the algorithms
for the fMRI.
We interpret the results.
And herein lies Problem A, which
we're not going to go
into any further, which
is the polemic of the
mind studying itself.
What I really wanted to talk
about today is to what extent
our own brains shape the way
we conceptualize the mind.
Let me just start by asking
a simple question.
How many of you people think
that the brain is the mind?
OK.
How many people think the brain
emerges from the mind?
is other than one of the
first two possibilities?
OK.
So what it amounts to is, as
soon as you ask that question,
what you realize is,
what is a mind?
I mean--
the mind is not a synapse.
It's not a neuron.
It's not something that you
weigh, measure, feel, pet,
stroke, talk, ask
questions to.
OK.
So what I really want to do is
talk about the brain as it
generates some of our concepts
of the mind and maybe to just
alter, if possible, the ways
we think about a mind.
I'm not going to give
you any answers.
If you think I know what the
mind is, the door's open.
So--
but before we do that, I want to
see one thing to Google and
at the same time be the
background of this talk.
This is something I
heard yesterday.
And it was someone in the
locker where I work out.
And he said--
and he said then, with a
perfectly straight face,
there's so much information,
I have trouble
keeping up with reality.
And what makes this funny, to
me, is that you're confusing
two concepts--
fact with reality.
And reality is a philosophical,
metaphysical conundrum.
It's not a scientific fact,
unless you believe that
everything is objective.
And that's it.
In which case, you're still
stuck with what are abstract
ideas, and so on.
But the difference is you
have facts at one level.
And you have ideas
at another level.
And the real question in going
from the brain to the mind is,
can you bridge that gap?
So a second of background--
I'm so old that I started in an
era where people believed
in mind-body dualism.
When I was a neurology resident,
one of the questions
you were commonly called on
to have to solve is, is a
patient's problem psychiatric
or neurologic?
As though there was
a difference.
Now we've gone 40 years
down the road.
And technology is obviously
spectacular compared to when I
first started out.
But there's an inherent,
underlying problem.
One has to translate
Neuroscience into a language
that's comprehensible.
It doesn't mean anything
to say that synapses
are firing at x-rate.
You have to know what that means
in terms of experience.
You have to have a language
for interpretation.
But the language, ironically,
of Neuroscience is the
language of popular culture, of
psychology, of philosophy,
movies, et cetera.
So in other words, when people
start an experiment, they say,
I'm going to the
study altruism.
OK.
That's a great idea.
But everybody has different
idea of altruism.
Some people think it's
self-serving and other people
think it's self-sacrificing.
But the concept of altruism
is not written in stone
somewhere, where you can study
it, get adequate data, and
suddenly say that data
represents an objective fact
at the level of the
definition.
So the circular arrows I have
there are because there's
become a peculiar recursive
phenomena.
As philosophy wants desperately
to keep up with
science, it takes the facts
of Neuroscience.
And as Neuroscience tries to
explain Neuroscience to the l
they use the language
of philosophy.
So you see all these books now
on free will, for example.
Well, free will it's not is
not a scientific piece of
information.
It is a concept that originally
arose out of a
theologic construct.
So I was just talking with Tom
a minute ago about the
computational aspects
of the brain.
So let's take the picture on the
left, which allegedly is a
reconstructed, three
dimensional
picture of a pain matrix.
Now imagine that you have
someone who tells you that
their toe hurts, and you
have that picture.
You say, well this corresponds
with the
person's subjective phenomena.
Now suppose you have the same
picture, and they tell you
they don't have any subjective
phenomenon.
Question is, how do you
interpret that?
Now there are loads of studies
on so-called neural correlates
of pain, including in
unconscious animals.
Now you get into a real
philosophical, psychological,
or metaphysical conundrum, of
what is unconscious pain?
So if you believe that this
report is the neural correlate
of pain, was it mean if you see
that someone who says they
don't have pain?
So there are obviously some
major issues that have arisen
in talking about different
levels.
And it's created and some
fabulous nonsense.
And I'll just let you look
through these real quickly.
These are all gathered
from good journals.
These are not from
garbage journals.
How about that one?
What does it mean to have
a site for free will?
And this one, I saw
this morning.
And here again is the problem.
"Unrealistic Optimism in the
Face of Reality" is in
Nature neuroscience
article this morning.
Or "fMRI Proves that
Pain is Real".
I mean, what else would it be?
But then it gets into the
definition of what is real.
This is one where they showed
a number of women some
pornographic pictures, and
they weren't aroused.
And they found an area of the
brain didn't light up like it
should in other women who were
aroused-- and therefore, the
conclusion, that the pain--
that libido problems were in
the brain, not the mind.
And I'm going--
misunderstanding of the
difference between the brain
and mind, I thought maybe that
there were people having a bad
hair day or something.
I mean the reasons are
infinite, but the
interpretation is
reductionist.
This one was particularly
spectacular.
The suggestion was that since
you can demonstrate neural
pathways or areas of brain that
light up for courage, the
theory is well maybe we can
stimulate courage through
trans-cranial magnetic
stimulation.
But the one that really
stopped me was--
a couple weeks ago,
this one came out.
Now does anybody think that a
baby five months old doesn't
have memory and consciousness?
Francis Crick once said a study
not worth is doing well.
But nevertheless, this is what
happens when you're trying to
prove something beyond
the area of data.
If they had said, we have seen
a certain neural activity
associated with babies at this
level of neural development,
hey, that's great!
Data is data.
The interpretation is
storytelling, which is really
going to be the punchline
of my little talk today.
But it's not just humorous.
It's changing our attitude in
ways that are fundamental and
kind of alarming.
So I want to actually present
a clinical case to you folks
and ask you to make
the diagnosis.
As you do, think about why
you came up with the
ideas that you did.
Keep in mind that one of the
real advantages of the Oliver
Sacks method of neurology is in
observing the patient and
talking to them and get the
steps that lead up to whatever
ideas or that emerges.
So the case was very simple, was
a young 25-year-old woman
who was in a massive automobile
accident,
unfortunately had devastating
brain damage.
She was left in what's called a
persistent vegetative state.
She would open your eyes but
did not look around, didn't
register, didn't respond, had
normal wake-sleep cycles, but
essentially had no response to
her outside environment.
And the regular MRI scan
showed massive
areas of brain damage.
But not all of her
cortex was--
there were preserved areas of
cortex and other areas that
were greatly damaged.
Well at the researchers did a
wonderful, technologically
sophisticated study.
They put that they put
headphones on her, put her
inside an fMRI scanner, and
asked her two questions.
One, can you imagine walking
around your house?
And number two, can you imagine
playing tennis?
And she had been an avid
tennis player before.
Now they then compared her fMRI
scan to normal controls.
And they were quite similar,
given variances fMRIs.
They were basically the same.
So her brain lit up
the same way as
normal, healthy controls.
How many of you people
would think that
she's therefore conscious?
OK.
Now let me say that she's
still lying there
unresponsive.
And now what we're left with
is a definition of
consciousness.
And how do you figure out what
represents consciousness?
Now I'm going to put aside that
consciousness can be a
variety of states from nightmare
to delirium to
confusion to they kind of
confusion you have when you
first awaken in the morning,
but you're still awake and
conscious, but you're
fuzzy in the head.
So there are lots of subjective
states of
consciousness, not just one.
It's not binary.
And there's also the
problem of arousal.
But put that aside
for the moment.
And then so you start to think
about, well, how much did you
bring to unconsciously versus
when do you know it was
consciously done?
So there are two aspects
to that question.
So the first is, we know that if
you're at a cocktail party
and you hear your name
mentioned, even though you
weren't listening, suddenly
you become aware of
conversation that you hadn't
heard earlier.
Well I've done lots of studies
that have shown that you can
process auditory and visual
information even when you're
unresponsive.
For example, on the lower end of
the scale, when mothers are
sleeping and you present a
bunch of names to them,
nothing happens.
You present the name of the
child, even though they don't
wake up, their EEG changes.
You can present people in coma
visual representations of
their family, and their brains
and cortical areas that are
lower levels than the total
cortical area will light up.
So what you're left with is a
fundamental question that has
not yet been answered.
I'm not even sure it's
addressable.
But it certainly hasn't been
answered is, how much of our
thought conscious?
And how much of our thought
actually is unconscious?
Then the question arises, in
this day and age, what would
you say to the family?
So here's what the authors said
in their article and said
the family.
And my question is that the
correct approach to modern
Neuroscience?
Would that be-- how many people
would vote that that is
what they should tell
the family?
Wouldn't it make more sense to
say, we see that she still
clinically unresponsive,
statistics in this group
patients is the recovery
is relatively limited.
But on the other hand, we have
this new information and it
may shed additional
light on this.
And we need to follow this up.
We need more.
We need to consider this.
But then what you realize is
what we're really down to is
again the problem
of definition.
So let me ask you a question,
how many people in this room
think you have complex,
conscious thought?
OK.
So let me just try and dissuade
you of that one.
The average the average person,
even at Google--
so average for Google, which
maybe you shift the Bell Curve
over 52 IQ points, whatever,
still can only remember seven
to nine digits.
Still if you take a complex
telephone number, you chunk it
into the area code, prefix,
suffix, et cetera.
We can only remember about four
chunks of information at
one time, at one time.
And that lasts for a minute or
two, so-called short term or
working memory.
That's all you could
do consciously.
You have the RAM of the first
computers ever made.
And I mean, itty bitty.
Now if you have a--
trying to do a complex thought
that involves, let's say,
myriad factors, let's say like
global climate change.
Now you come up with four or
five factors, like you got to
invest in Greenland
or the role of
polar bear or whatever.
Then suddenly somebody gives you
another set of five, you
can't keep those five in along
with the other four.
So it's like having an--
what do they call those?
Etch-a-Sketch?
Where you have to erase or store
that memory, in order to
put more in-- your random
access memory
of short term memory.
Once it's in your unconscious,
it's subject to every single
bias that your unconscious
brain has.
And you don't need for me to
tell you that that's the
subject of everything--
Daniel Kahneman books.
I mean, it's everywhere we are
understanding the biases of
the unconscious.
So what it amounts to-- once
you're down in outside of
awareness--
If a Blue Jay flies over here,
it may change my idea about
what is global warming,
for example.
OK.
Now let me ask the same question
again, how many of
you people believe in complex,
conscious thought?
It doesn't change anything
what I tell you.
And that's really
what I wanted--
this is what of this is
going to be about.
[LAUGHTER]
Something's wrong because we
know-- we all feel that.
OK.
Some years ago, I wrote a book
--five years ago-- a book
called "On Being Certain".
And in it, what I finally
realized is that, in addition
to having the computational
skills of your brain, your
brain has to notify yourself
what's going
on outside of awareness.
So you take for example--
I look out at faces.
Now, I don't recognize
most of you.
But I recognize that
you're all people.
I mean it that much--
or mostly.
That's a pattern recognition
that's going unconsciously.
But I don't have any sense
of recognition.
But if I recognize somebody
sitting in the front row,
let's say, I will also--
my brain, if it wants to draw
attention to it, will say,
that's Peter Norvig,
let's say.
So you if you think about
it, we have systems for
understanding ourselves
in our environment.
That's sight, sound, so on.
We have somatic sensations
for the external world.
We have visceral sensations
for internal world.
But we obviously must have
some kind of subjective
sensation for what goes
on computationally.
It just doesn't go on--
it goes on in silence,
the computation.
But then you have
to be notified.
If there's 3% chance that I
recognize someone in the
audience, maybe it doesn't
reach the threshold.
I don't notice it.
It reaches 60% as
a competition.
Not only do you get
the computation.
But you get a message.
The Message says, I recognize
that person.
And then at 100%, you say that's
absolutely Joe Blow.
And the same kind of idea
goes for thought.
If you have a hunch, and it's
such a low level that you
don't pay attention to it.
Then you say, I don't know.
That might be right.
That's worth pursuing.
Oh, um, to an ah ha, which
is an absolute certainty.
But nobody here can
generate an ah ha.
An ah ha happens to you.
It is a sensation.
It is the same thing as an itch
or a pain, only it's a
glorious sensation.
So what finally occurred to me
is that we have a number of
involuntary mental sensations
that generate much of what we
experience is a mind.
Let's put aside emotions and
moods and a small amount
memory that we can have
in random access.
But when I asked you the
question about how many people
think you still complex
conscious thought.
The question is why?
Because we experience it.
So we're having an experience.
So let me ask you--
put it another way.
What if you go to bed at night,
and you're trying to
remember Charlie Brown's name,
and you can't remember it.
Wake up in the morning,
and you remember it.
And you say, it just
occurred me.
It popped into my mind,
whatever you say.
You have no sensation of
thinking, is that correct?
It just occurs to you.
That's why people talk about
muses and so on.
But if you try really hard to
remember Charlie Brown's name,
you have a sense of effort.
You have a sense that you're
thinking about it.
So the real question is, is
brain working differently
under those two circumstances?
And how would you know?
It seems unlikely that your
heart beats differently when
you feel it beating than
if and when you don't.
By the same token, it seems
unlikely that your brain would
have a mechanism where it
switches back and forth.
If you're aware of it,
it works in one way.
And if you're not aware of
it, it works completely
differently.
So what's the difference?
The difference is the way
you feel about it.
So if you're trying to study a
really hard calculus problem,
and you feel like you're
putting a lot
of effort into it.
So you say, I study
really hard.
I thought really hard
about that.
But suppose you wake up in the
morning with the answer to
that problem, you don't have
any sense of effort at all.
None.
So if you go back to the diagram
previously about
little, small nubbin of purely
conscious thought, but it's
all we experience.
That's how we think we all
have conscious, complex
thought, irrespective
of what you might
surmise from the data.
OK?
And my one point is they
are different.
There are the sensory
phenomena.
And there are the
computations.
And just as an aside, for those
people who are of the
old school and have studied
the Chinese box experiment
about whether AI has--
whether a computer can really
understand, is a confusion
about the difference between
computation and sensation.
Computers do really great
at whatever they do.
It's in the semantics of
understanding that they don't
have the sensory phenomena
that gives us a sense of
understanding.
But they may come up with
the same net result.
And it may well surpass us.
So you have two aspects.
If you think about AI,
that's computation.
If you think that the future
of AI, if you want to make
true robots are human beings,
you'll have figure out what
the sensory phenomena are.
And that's really the hard
problem of consciousness.
Whether we can ever
get there--
you can debate about that.
But unless you're clairvoyant,
I can't tell you
which is more likely.
So if you think about it, it's
not just pattern recognition
equals recognition sensation.
But there are a whole
host of sensations.
Feeling and knowing,
I just mentioned.
What I'd like to just start
with something that we all
know but kind of deny.
We have physical dimensions
of a sense of self.
For example, if I stimulate a
certain area of the brain, I
can create out of
body sensations.
This can happen with people
with brain tumors, with
certain forms epilepsy.
What it amounts to those we
can actually, with virtual
reality, shift one's own
personal sense of self.
Because our sense of self comes
from our lives, in terms
of where we think
we're located.
So if you look out at the world,
you're seeing it from
wherever perspective
of your eye.
Now if I put a virtual reality
apparatus on your eyes, but
then have the camera start from
a different position,
like from the vantage point of
a nearby mannequin, people
will feel that they are located
inside the mannequin.
And then you can come up to that
mannequin with a knife
and try and stab
the mannequin.
And the person will actually
experience increased heart
rate, sweating, and a feeling
of anxiety because he
actually-- even though he
knows, cognitively, that
that's not him, he can't control
the feeling that he's
actually inside the mannequin.
So these body swap illusion's
clearly tell you that the
brain creates a physical
sense of self.
It's an involuntary sensation.
Also creates a sense
of ownership--
and by ownership, I mean, if you
raise your arm like this
you feel like you've done
it voluntarily and
that it's your arm.
If you go to a doctor's office,
and he raises your
arm, it's still your arm.
But you no long feel that
you did it yourself.
We have very good body
part recognition.
If we have good recognition for
our body parts, then we
also have a sense of ownership
of our mind.
It's my mind.
And these are my thoughts.
We can't get away from the
fact and when we have a
thought, we thought we thought
it, because of the feelings.
We can have a feeling that
since we have a sense of
agency that we generated the
thought, and that a sense of
agency is part of what makes
Thought A feel like it
generates Thought B.
Now it's hard to say this and
fully accept this because all
we experience is Thought A
causes Thought B. So even
while I'm talking to you here, I
believe that I'm making some
clever set sentences following
a linear fashion But if you
think about it, the brain
works in parallel.
Myriad things going
on simultaneously.
So Mike's sensation of a linear
thought may actually be
a misrepresentation, what
is occurring at
an unconscious level.
But let me go on.
So if you have a sense of
ownership of your body parts
and a constrained
physical self--
they've even shown, for example,
that if you have
damage to your amygdala, it will
change how close you can
get to other people.
If you have damage to you
amygdala, instead-- our normal
interpersonal distance of other
people's a few feet.
People who have these
damaged--
they have no sense
of restriction.
Similarly, there are kids with
Williams syndrome, which is a
genetic disorder, with this--
and they don't have a
sense of distance.
So we have sense of a body and
involuntarily generated sense
of self, distance from other
people, sense of agency, sense
of body ownership, sense of that
we're thinking, agency
choice and causation.
And I go into some detail.
I really have time today
to go into it.
Basically, these constitute
the cognitive mental
sensations that make up what we
experience when we're thinking.
And the fundamental paradox
is that these involuntary
mechanisms give you a sense of
a unique, willful self in
action, thinking, making
deliberate choices,
determining causation.
Now this is hard to swallow
at first glance.
Because it goes against
everything we believe as
rational man.
But the evidence is, in my mind,
is really staggering.
So it's at least worth
considering.
So if you think about it, what
do we experience when where we
experience thoughts from the
standpoint that I mentioned?
We have perceptions.
We have emotions and moods.
That's it.
And that is the tool that
is studying the mind.
That is the mind that's trying
to study itself.
And if you think about it from
a standpoint that you're
driving down the road of life,
we have what you might think
of as a mental dashboard.
Some people are born skeptics,
like myself.
And other people are
know-it-alls, who seem like
they have the answer
for everything.
And we can argue that all the
personality traits that might
go into the difference.
But the fact of the matter is
I don't get very often a
feeling of knowing.
I know that even when I write
this book, and I think, oh,
isn't this clever.
I pick it up the next day.
And I say, is that right?
I mean, there's something
elusive about that feeling of
understanding that I don't
particularly have.
Other people, I'm sure you've
heard them stand up here and
say, this is the way it is.
And they dogmatically say,
there isn't any other
possibility.
And we've always attribute that
to psychological maladies
and arrogance and so on.
But the fact of matter is it may
well be at least in part,
if not primarily, because at
a different tweaking of how
strongly your mental sensations
various varieties I
mentioned come into play.
Now you can think of this
from another standpoint.
You think of optimism,
pessimism, risk-reward.
Some people are risk aversives
Other people are not.
And if you take the studies on
identical twins raised apart,
what you find out is that a good
percentage, over 50% of
the character traits are shared
irrespective of no
environment.
So it's nature plus nurture.
But there's a considerable
degree sharing
of personality traits.
If you consider these
involuntary mental sensations
as of another form of
personality traits, you start
to see, get a picture, for each
of us is comprised of
different senses of agency or
your feelings of causation.
For example, somebody takes
melatonin and goes to sleep.
And they wake in the morning
and say, I got
this new wonder drug.
It cures sleeplessness.
Someone says, I took
melatonin.
I went to sleep.
I don't know if they're
related.
And you always think, well, the
guy that made a conclusion
based on an n of
1 is an idiot.
But it doesn't work
quite like that.
They actually have that very
strong feeling that's how--
of causation.
That a lead to b led to c, where
someone doesn't have it.
So if you think about people in
general, each one of us is
a mixture of all of these
various traits in different
proportions.
If you imagine we have dials or
different settings, we're
all different.
And it explains some of the
enormous difficulty in
communication with each other.
Because you have to be at the
same level of a certain thing.
If you take a know-it-all and
the skeptic, they have nothing
to talk about.
They just--
They can't communicate.
So if you think about these
involuntary mental sensations,
you come with a another way
of thinking about a lot of
different kinds of mental
illness also.
For example, in people with
obsessive compulsive disorder,
they turn off the gas.
They walk out the door and say,
whoops, I'm not sure I
turned off the gas.
So they come back in the room
turn off the gas again on the
stove, do it four or five times,
10 times, 20 times.
They can never be satisfied that
the gas is turned off.
You say to them,
look, it's off.
The dial is off.
There's no--
And they can't stop.
And what you realize is that
they have no sensation of
knowing whatsoever.
They can't know it
Even though--
at the level of feeling.
They know it at the level
of cognition.
And it's this discrepancy that
you see in so many so-called
mental disorders.
You see it in the opposite,
people with delusional states
that are convinced that
something's wrong or that the
Martian have tapped
into their Wi-Fi.
It's very hard to dissuade them
because it's a feeling
of, on the other extreme,
a feeling of certainty.
But even the body schema image
disorders, which we sort of
understand, but we kind of
attribute to psychological
factors, whether or not
that's true or not
--it may well be true--
but the bottom line is it ends
up as a problem of your
representational map.
For example, a couple weeks
ago, they showed an
interesting study that if I walk
through a doorway when it
is only 25% wider that I am, I
will start to turn sideways
just to avoid bumping
into something.
But people with anorexia
do this when it's
between 40 and 50% wider.
They actually see themselves
as bigger.
And I was talking to a woman,
recently, who were--
bariatric surgeon.
She said you can take the
weight off but you can't
change the body image.
So you start to see is feelings
about the self are
deeply ingrained.
And they are the starting point
for thinking of the mind
as an experience.
Now as we go forward in
Neuroscience, we will--
brain will become progressively
unraveled.
Our mind's unraveling for
different reasons.
But I mean the knowledge
about the brain.
But as concept it's--
whatever we think about the
mind is generated by these
experiences.
That is part of the fundamental
problem.
That's why I showed the first
slide of the mind trying to
conceive of itself.
Because we've got involuntary
aspects of brain function that
are shaping the very way we
think about the mind.
Now, I want to just give
you a quick example.
When I asked you the question
before, is the brain, is the
mind just a brain, or did it
emerge from the brain?
Most people feel that it's
one or the other.
And I think only a couple people
raised their hand,
saying that it's more
than the brain.
Now it's true that everything
we do emanates
ultimately from the brain.
But if you think about
information, where it comes
from, perhaps it's greater
than the brain.
How would you know that?
So let me just present one of
my curiosity speculations.
Now I don't know how many people
realize this, but slime
mold loves oat bran
And two wonderful
studies have been done.
One in which you take oat bran
and you paste it on the major
cities in England.
And the slime mold, which has no
nervous system whatsoever,
will merge together from
individual little cells into a
multi-nucleated that single,
giant organism.
And it will seek out
the oat bran in a
way that's most efficient.
So they take a topographic map
of England, and the slime-mold
recreates the British
highway system.
And they've done this for
Japan, same thing.
They put on the major
cities at it
recreates the railway system.
So they asked the one who did
the Japanese study, well does
mean slime mold's intelligent?
They have no nervous
system whatsoever.
And the man said, the researcher
said, it depends
what you mean by intelligence.
But he said from a mathematical
standpoint, it's
approximately the same degree
of complexity as a person
learning to ride a bicycle, same
degree of complexity as
in the cerebellum as
riding a bicycle.
So let me present my second
example of what I'd like you
to at least consider.
In the '20s there was thought
that there were
two types of locusts.
Solitary locusts, and in
academic jargon, they were
considered gregarious
if they swarmed.
And solitary locusts
are vegetarian.
They live by themselves, are
very finicky eaters.
And normally live
lives like that.
However, if they get into a
circumstance, such as in
Africa, where it rains,
they breed like crazy.
And then the rain goes away, now
there are a lot of locusts
and there are no water.
The locust changes to the
so-called swarming locust.
You've all seen pictures
of them by the million.
And the first thing they start
to do, where they make these
little marching movements
with their feet.
And then they start eating
each other, eating
everything in sight.
They're voracious eaters.
They actually become
cannibals.
What's interesting to me is
that their brain changes.
Their visual cortex changes from
being primarily optimized
for solitary acquisition of food
to group hunting so for
group acquisition of food.
So the entire cortex changes
it's higher hierarchy--
visual cortex.
Their muscles in their
legs change.
There's 30% more muscle bulk.
Their color changes,
et cetera.
Well it turned out about 10
years ago that there are
little hairs on the
back of locusts.
And you stroke them, and
they release serotonin.
And the serotonin levels in
the brain dramatically
elevated when you do this.
And so they found that this
happens we get to a certain
critical density
in enclosures.
And you can completely block
this warming effect by
blocking serotonin
in the brain.
So here you have animals that
their brain changes in their
group context.
Yes, the impetus starts with
the individual body.
But it's a part of a
group phenomenon.
I won't occur on its own.
Now I don't know how many of you
people have been in a rock
concert or something.
And when you're leaving, there
are a bunch of people you
start going like this no to hit
the guy in front of you.
You say, I'm doing is not
the walk into the
guy in front of me.
Well there's no way to know
whether you're doing it for
that reason or this is a group
phenomenon that occurs at a
rock contest.
Now I don't really care about
what this means, personally,
in terms that walking.
But it tells you something about
the feelings of agency
dictate how we think about the
mind in terms of doing the
studies we do.
We want to study empathy.
You put a solitary person in an
fMRI scan and you give them
empathy questionnaire
or you show a video.
But what if empathy is
a group phenomena.
You'd never see it in an fMRI
scan of one person.
Now imagine, to me one of the
most onerous things of the
20th century was the Nuremberg
rallies, people on their own
act one way.
And in a group they act
quite different.
And you say, oh, they're
making choices.
Well we don't know that.
And we don't know how to study
that with present day
Neuroscience.
Whether in the future that's
possible would depend on a
massive increase
in technology.
But I mention this because the
way we think about ourselves
as individuals and how we
conceptualize the mind is
being restricted to that little
thing behind your
forehead is determined by
mechanisms in your brain not
by any fundamental higher
level reality.
And it impairs how we actually
think about who we are, both
as individuals and
as a society.
One of the things that's always
struck me is the sense
of uniqueness has particularly
extended to our
treatment of animals.
I know that when I was in
medical school, they told us
we should take out the pancreas
of a stray dog, so we
could watch how it suffered when
it died from diabetes.
And nobody even considered the
fact that they were taking a
dog and doing it.
I still have nightmares
about that.
Even today though, some of the
best Neuroscientists, people I
really respect, are writing
books about the science behind
what makes us unique.
Now we think we're unique
because we have these feelings
of uniqueness.
So it's ironically it's our
biology dictates our sense of
uniqueness.
The feeling tells us
that we're unique.
But hey, that's no different
with Sarah Palin says.
It's the same argument.
And certainly, at some point,
we should start to consider
what these involuntary
sensations mean towards our
public policy, et cetera.
And now on that not let me just
say that five years ago,
I gave you talk on
my last book.
And I showed this slide.
And I smugly said, this is an
example of how we feel that
top slide is longer than
the bottom slide.
And I said, this is an example
of how we have a feeling of
knowing which is involuntary.
Even I tell you the slide--
the two lengths are the same.
We still feel the other one.
So it's a feeling of knowing
at odds with our cognitive
understanding.
And I thought wasn't
that clever.
But what I didn't realize is
that this isn't just a matter
of our brains in the abstract.
They've done studies now, which
came out within a year
or two ago, that they gave the
same pictures to different
kinds of cultures.
From the so-called Western
technology, highly educated
kids, to tribes in Africa.
Tribes in Africa don't
see a difference.
They see no illusion
here whatsoever.
And they've tried this
with other things.
And the conclusion of the
authors is that something as
basic as our visual perception
can be changed by our culture.
So you go back, you think
about the locust,
you think on this.
We need to rethink how
Neuroscience thinks about the
mind, not the brain.
You can study the
brain without--
that's pure science.
So I just--
so I leave some time for
questions, I want to emphasize
the study the brain
as pure science.
I've no qualms with
that whatsoever.
And there's no other way of
studying the world from the
point of view of facts.
But conclusions about what the
mind is are storytelling.
I can give you an argument that
we have a group mind.
I can tell you that
we don't have one.
But I don't have any evidence
to support that.
That's pure speculation.
I can tell you we're unique.
We're not unique.
I could tell you we're
studying altruism.
Those are stories that you're
telling based upon the data.
And so it's from my point, the
science of the mind is one set
of stories among many.
Science uses data.
Stories use plot
and character.
And all I want to share
something with you.
How many people think we all
know what this lovely young
lady is thinking through
Neuroscience?
Wouldn't it be great to be a
mind reader, to know what
animals are thinking?
But the fact of matter is if
you realize that we have to
have perfect understanding
what's going on in her brain,
and that she's got to
be able to tell us.
So--
But there are other ways.
In writing my books, I've
been kind of ignorant of
what came before me.
And I thought I'd
close with this.
Aristotle said, "Our desires
harbor a hidden judgment that
their ends are good." Basically,
2,500 years ago, he
was telling us that our
unconscious mind also is
making unconscious judgments,
such as
the feeling of knowing.
And Dostoevsky was commenting
on conscious versus
unconscious though.
"Soon he sank in the deep
thought, or accurately
speaking, into a complete
blindness of mind." This is
written in the 1860."
And for those of you who would
like to debate the free will
issue, I think Tolstoy
summed this up.
"You say I'm not free.
But I've raised and
lowered my arm.
Everybody understands that
this logical answer is
irrefutable proof of freedom."
He understands the paradoxical
nature of any discussion
about free will.
And as far as so-called
group mind.
I'll leave you Charles
Bukowski's idea "If you could
separate what the public thinks
from reality, that's
all you need to know
to bet wisely."
And I think this is the state
of Neuroscience at present.
So I will now answer questions
or look stupid as best I can.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: If you could take
that slider that had that
sense of uncertainty about and
adjust it for you just once,
you only have one opportunity
to do this, how
would you do it?
Would you be more sure of your
inferences or less sure?
ROBERT BURTON: More
sure of my--
AUDIENCE: More sure of your
inferences and your thoughts
and ideas and you
come up or less?
ROBERT BURTON: I think that if
you don't have some certainly,
at least, to the extent of
feeling you got a hunch,
you're never going
to do anything.
You're not going to
write a novel.
Like, I've written
several novels.
You've have to think, I'm
on the right track.
But you can have so much
uncertainty that you think
that character has to do A or
B and can't do C, D, or
F, you follow me?
So it's--
You need the middle road.
How's that?
That's a simple way
of putting it.
AUDIENCE: That's just
copping out.
ROBERT BURTON: I know.
I think you have to
wear two hats.
You wear an editor and
a non editor hat.
In other words, when I'm writing
fiction, I say, leave
the editor at home.
Try everything.
And then I'm going to go back
and visit with my editor's hat
on and see if it makes sense.
So I take no certainty is the
default position for trying to
create ideas.
And then as much as I can do
certainty to try disprove
actually what I've written.
AUDIENCE: So you want control
of the slider all the time.
ROBERT BURTON: No.
I want it on off for a while and
then go back and reach for
it if I can.
But you can't do that either.
I know that.
You asked a tough question.
You guys all do.
So go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What is your attitude
towards the unknown,
for which we don't have the
tools currently to understand
within a scientific framework.
ROBERT BURTON: Couple things.
One is, that if I had an answer
for you, I would be
clairvoyant.
By very definition, those people
who say, I think in '50
years or 20 years or 10 years or
next week or sometime we're
going to understand the mind,
they're making a prediction
based upon clairvoyance,
not facts.
And if I told you we weren't,
I would also be
basing it on no facts.
So now--
so basically, I'm just
speculating.
My own feeling is that there's
certain insurmountable
metaphysical questions that,
even if we were to get great
understanding of the brain,
which I have no doubt that
down the road the techniques
will be such that this will
look like primitive man.
But really what it amounts to is
can we bridge that into the
subjective description.
In other words, for example,
let's say your foot hurts and
my foot hurts.
But we have a whole different
backgrounds,
for whatever reason.
We would need to have perfect
information about each of us
for our entire lives, not
just for this instant.
And then we would have to
have the same language.
But even if we had the same
language, like I worked at a
pain clinic at UCSF, where
people would say their
paying was a 10.
But their 10 isn't the
same as your 10.
So you have the problem of
qualia, or is you're red the
same as my red.
Now do I think you
can solve those?
I like the idea of mystery.
I know it's not going to be
solved in my lifetime.
So I enjoy the idea
of mystery.
But I love the idea
of discovery.
So it's sort of like
extended foreplay.
This is not exactly--
AUDIENCE: So your attitude is
a curiosity and appreciation
for mystery.
ROBERT BURTON: Yeah, and If you
get to my age, and you see
the history of science unfold
in front of your own eyes,
during your lifetime, we've
made a zillion mistakes.
Now to think that somewhere down
the road, we won't make
them is to misunderstand the
nature of human beings.
Science works in little steps,
little increments forward,
some steps backward, sideways,
with the idea of moving
inexorably towards moving
inexorably, but not towards
any final conclusion.
Now but that's speculation.
And that's a novelist looking
at the fact that I like the
idea there are multiple
explanations.
AUDIENCE: At the beginning you
showed a picture of the brain
studying the brain.
And I think that this is kind of
part of a trend of looking
more at the history and further
back in the process of
what we're doing.
So just acknowledging the fact
that we have these brains that
have flaws.
And that's what we're
using to do it.
And then the next step that
I think about is using
evolution, so thinking about
the evolved brain
studying the brain.
But I'm kind of a skeptic
towards evolutionary
psychology.
I guess you might be
somewhat as well.
Do you have any hope for
bringing evolution to this
picture more?
More so than just the very
simple things like, say, the
size of the visual cortex, but
more complicated things like
ability to do certain kinds
of computation,
or things like that.
ROBERT BURTON: A
couple things.
First of all, evolution
happened.
But evolution isn't an entity
with an agenda.
I don't know how many of you
people know Stephen J Gould
and the concept of standards,
but it's worth reading about.
But we assign purpose to
everything but without any
knowledge that's so.
So as far as computational
ability, if we're going to
survive, I think it's more
important we develop empathy
and compassion and getting
along with others than
computational ability.
Because unfortunately, my
concern, which is probably why
I've written these books, is
that we will get smarter.
We will get more-- and whatever
tools we can get
personally--
let's face it, you guys
are and evolution.
If you have a PDA or a flash
drive, you can down--
when I was a neurologist, if
you could just memorize all
the diseases, and you could walk
around about the latest
literature, you were a genius.
Now you don't have to
do any of that.
So in a way, that
is evolution.
It's a different kind
of evolution.
But it isn't making
us any better.
It isn't solve any problems
in Congress Or
climate change or anything.
So if I were to say, I think
that before we worry about
computational improvements in
the individual, we will have
them as a group mind,
an extended mind.
But I don't know that that's
terribly helpful for what
really counts, which is to
understand that we're fallible
and that we have to be a bit
humbled that each of our ideas
comes from an idiosyncratic and
often irrational place,
even though it may be the best
we can do with science.
We augment it with science.
But we still have a lot
of in-built biases.
Now that's just a personal
sermon, not
a scientific comment.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wonder if you can talk about
the connections between
Capgras' syndrome and
consciousness and whether
there are--
we can describe such a thing as
defects of consciousness?
ROBERT BURTON: Let me--
there are a whole bunch of
so-called delusional
miss-identification syndromes.
And actually it's--
in my first book, I cover this
at some length because what
really is of interest to me--
I'll give you an example
because maybe--
if you guys have time to stick
around, it's a quick--
I had a patient many years ago,
who had a very, very,
very, very, very small stroke
was recovered within a few
hours and was fine but
was an art dealer.
And he phoned me up
when you go home.
An he said something
horribles happened.
I said, what's that?
He says, my desk has been
replaced by an limitation.
And what he had was a 12 foot
refractory desk, refectory
table, that you would you'd have
to take the doors off to
get it out.
So it was pretty obvious that
hadn't been replaced.
And he understood that.
But when he ran his across the
table top, he said, yes, those
are the wormholes.
[INAUDIBLE]
and those are the scuff
marks and everything.
They're exactly like before.
But they don't feel familiar.
They don't feel like
they used to.
I said, well, they're
the same size?
And he was in total agreement
as to the cognitive
aspects of that desk.
But he could not convince
himself that it wasn't an
invitation because they
didn't feel familiar.
And that case was one of the
ones that started me to think
about the discrepancy between
understanding, cognitive
understanding--
he understood that
it was a desk.
But he couldn't grasp
that it was his.
And so basically that
sensation is--
you say with consciousness.
Consciousness for him was
a combination of the
intellectual knowledge.
It came as a fact
and the feeling.
So yes.
The Capgras syndrome those
delusions are a form of
disorders of involuntary
mental states which are
reflected in consciousness, if
that answers your question.
AUDIENCE: Well, more
specifically, do you think
that we can understand
consciousness as sort of a
continuum that can
be degraded.
You can measure the level
of degradation
based on certain defects.
ROBERT BURTON: Oh, there's
no question.
If it's like consciousness
goes like that, if
that's what you mean.
Yes.
And you're aware of this,
out the periphery, and
then it drops off.
And I suppose all these are
elements-- yes, if you got
them all together, you'd have
a better idea of what
consciousness is.
AUDIENCE: So it just reminded
your question on this mind
versus brain [INAUDIBLE].
So there in Buddhism
there is this--
Buddha has this-- there is a
story about Buddha that were
14 question, if I remember
correctly, that he was never
ready to make any
answer about.
So one of them was
something like--
I think these three questions
were exactly among these 14
question that Buddha
was never--
So when he was asked this
question, he was just--
didn't say anything.
So I just wondered whether your
attitude is more like--
is something that is not
meaningful question?
Of is it something that--
so that it's inherently a
stupid question or is it
something that maybe answered
in the future?
ROBERT BURTON: There are
different kinds of questions.
There are some that are
meaningful but seem like
they're very difficult.
Obviously, it's meaningful ask
what is consciousness.
On the other hand, to ask what
is free will is a different
kind of question.
Because, to me, free will,
the very question--
first of all, the word free
will doesn't make sense.
Because what kind of will
would there be?
And you think, well, how is it
that everybody writes books on
free will without even saying
what does that word mean?
Now if you go back and think
about it from a historical
perspective, it was really
pounded into the public mind
by Augustine in the year 300.
Now why is it that 1800 years
later, we're still debating
it, when after 1800 years, you
haven't got an answers?
So to me, one possibility
is maybe the
question makes no sense.
But then it gets down to how you
think about determinism,
and various levels of
determinism versus emergent
behavior, and then you guys
standing here talk about
compatiblism which
makes no sense.
But what it amounts to is the
original question doesn't--
for example, what came
before the beginning?
Well, that's a language
question.
It's like it Wittgenstein
once said, it is
afternoon on the sun.
Now I you have to laugh
when you hear that.
You go, that's a
great sentence.
We should learn from those
kind of nonsense things.
And this book, How Something
Comes from Nothing--
all the latest physics--
well, that again is an attempt
to distort a paradox.
So those questions that are
really meaningful, the really
hard to grasp, like
how does the brain
create subjective response.
And there are just like, huh?
Why bother to ask
that question?
So it runs the gamut.
But that's my cynicism.
That's not skepticism.
That's cynicism.
They're closely allied.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT BURTON: Thanks.